[Music]
was i speeding officer you don't look
like you're from around here no sir
you've been doing any drugs tonight
no sir nope which pop that trunk step
out a vehicle for me please really no
drugs huh nope well well well you
planted that in my car did I or did I
plant this I I guess it's the car whoa
whoa what do we have here huh these are
colors homie No or are these your colors
or perhaps these are your colors or are
these look at all these colors man you
sure got a lot of color look at all of
these colors are you a real cop freeze
what is that hmm well well well it looks
like an illegal firearm or is it
I don't I don't know what this is I'm
sorry
pick a card it's not even a good fan any
card you can just stick there okay you
took that card yeah now can you remember
that card yes can you commit that card
to memory this is unbelievable have you
done so have you yes please insert the
card back into the deck random done it's
in a different place than where you took
it originally there we are there I take
the deck like so I give it a slow CIL's
and abacus voice is this your call no
are you sure I want your badge number
how did you do that and that is for you
after all that you're still giving me a
ticket is it a ticket or is it a
two-for-one coupon for my show at the
magic house Thursday night at 11 p.m.
your call
I'll take the ticket
you